Hello!
Oh, where am I?
Oh, hey!
Magic trick.
Abracadabra.
Hello everybody!
Hello, hello.
Welcome.
I wasn't supposed to stream today.
I was gonna take today off because I was gonna be like, you know, I'll only stream during the round robins because like, I don't want people to know.
I mean like, they can see my progress on other people's streams, but like, I didn't want to make it easy for people to see where I'm at skill level wise.
I didn't want to make it easy for people to know how bad I am.
They have to actively find me on other people's streams.
Anyway, um, I decided to, um, I decided to stream today because today we have a very special coach today.
Uh, we have, yes, Jaewon.
He is famous and infamous for many moments and, uh, classic moments in the FGC community.
Yes, let's go Justin!
Let's go Justin!
I swear to God.
If I hear any of you guys go, let's go Tokie.
I swear to fucking God, you don't want me to win.
Anyway.
Um, I, okay.
I legitimately did not know that was him.
Like, that was him and in EVO Moment 37.
I, I actually didn't realize that was him in EVO Moment 37 until people kept like linking it, I was like that's him?
Oh my God.
That's him?
I was like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought, the one I, the clip I do know where Justin came from was the, cause that, that clip I know very well, um, the, the Mortal Kombat clip.
That was actually, like, my very first introduction to, to, to Jaewon.
And that was, that was the, the clip I actually knew where he's from.
And, uh, you're gonna learn today.
Like, I quote that sometimes.
So, like, when I found out, I was like, wait, Jaewon is, is you gonna learn today, guy?
I, I didn't realize that was him.
Until, like, I was like, oh my god, it's him.
He's, you gotta learn today, man.
That's him.
Anyway, um, I saw that he is apparently, um, really good at modern gif.
And, um, he offered his, like, expertise as an assistant coach.
To any of the Sajam Slammers.
So, I was like, I'm playing modern gif.
He plays modern gif.
So, like, I was like, you know, I'm just gonna ask him if he's free.
Like, I'm just gonna ask him if he's, like, free and if he's, like, open to, like, coaching me on some modern gif, zen gif.
Because, like, he did offer.
So, I hit him up and I was like, oh yeah, can you, like, coach me?
Like, I don't know what I'm doing.
Like, um, and he was like, yeah, sure.
And that's why today we have a stream.
Because I thought, might as well.
I mean, I am collaborating with one of the, uh, most well-known FGC competitors, um, in the scene.
I mean, that man has, like, what, nine EVO champion titles?
Which is a lot.
That's actually a lot, now that I think about it.
Um, um, one of the most well-known, um, FGC, uh, competitors in the community.
So, I was like, yeah, I should stream.
I was like, I should stream.
Is it fucked that I haven't had a stream with my actual coach, but have a stream?
My first stream.
My first coaching session stream isn't even with, like, my actual coach.
Hey, I was at my coach's stream earlier today.
Chat.
I was at... if you checked Brian F's VODs, I was there.
I was there.
I just didn't stream it on my own channel.
But like, you're gonna see Brian in like, for like three other streams.
Guys, there's round robin one, there's round robin two, and there's finals.
But there's only one J1 stream, okay?
Like, in the end, in the end, it balances out.
It balances out everybody.
I was at two Brian streams, okay.
I was at two of his streams.
I just didn't stream it myself.
Hey, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
You have an actual coach.
Yes.
I finally like got coaching yesterday
It was actually pretty good, because like I I finally know like the fundamentals, because I have no idea what I'm doing.
I still don't know what I'm doing.
I'll let you know right now.
I...
I like Tekken more than Street Fighter after learning both games.
The number one reason why...
Let me explain.
The number one reason why is that in Tekken, I don't have to block.
I can just be aggressive throughout it as a grappler.
But in Street Fighter, I actually have to block and it's not fun.
It's so frustrating.
I've never been so angry before.
Like I've actually never been so fucking mad.
Like playing Street Fighter is...
Exactly!
I did not pay $70 to fucking block, but I have to.
It's so bullshit.
Like it's so fucking bullshit that I have to block.
And like...
And I found out that like in Street Fighter, like I have to like use my brain.
Because I can't button mash in Street Fighter.
It's... I'm so mad.
I actually... I can't button mash.
I can't button mash in Street Fighter.
Like because it doesn't...
It doesn't do anything.
It punishes you more than like...
Than like Tekken.
So... I don't know if you guys know this but in...
Okay maybe you do.
It's sort of very noticeable.
But in Tekken I like do moves that I sort of know how to do.
And I also like mix in button mashing at the same time.
So like...
I do have moves that I can do.
I know what I'm doing, but I also mix in button mashing to keep myself random and unpredictable, so now I'm like, no, now I am predictable, because I can't button mash!
So, it's so frustrating.
Anyway, I know I am not the best player in my division, 100%, I know for sure.
Like, everybody was fucking grinding.
Like, I think, like, I've been playing Street Fighter the last three days, but like, I know I'm very behind.
I'm currently Silver 1 at the moment, and like, I know I'm not the best player in my division, but like, I'm gonna try so fucking hard to not be the worst player.
Like, my goal, my goal is to be better.
Better than one person.
That's all I care about.
That's...
That's actually...
As long as I'm...
Sorry, I had Jwon stream on, just because I want to know if he's, like, what he's doing right now.
So, if you heard, like, you heard her sound in the background, I was like, okay, what is he talking about?
Anyway, I told Jwon I just want to talk to you guys first before, like, I'm ready...
I'm ready to be in the call.
But yeah, basically, like, just not the worst.
That's, like, all I care about.
As long as, like, I'm not the worst player in my division, like, I'm happy.
And that's why I need...
I need Justin to, like...
I need him to fix me.
I literally...
I literally changed my Street Fighter schedule just so I could be coached by him.
Because, like, when it...
When...
Even when Bryan had, like, you know, a real...
A natural life.
Like, an actual life where he...
He couldn't coach after, like, 8pm.
Like, I didn't care.
Like, I was just like, alright, I'm willing to, like, have fun, like, secondhand coaching.
Like, trickle-down coaching from Brawl Pro.
Like, I...
Because I was just like...
I was like, I don't want to...
I don't want to play Street Fighter so early.
But then...
But I changed my schedule.
I changed...
I changed my...
My...
My Street Fighter schedule so I could get coached by Justin.
I'm sorry, Bryan.
Like, I didn't change it for you.
I changed it for Justin.
I...
Guys!
You would have done the same thing.
Don't fucking...
You would have done the same...
Thing.
Like...
You guys...
Like, don't fucking judge me.
Because I know all of you would have done the same thing if you were getting coached by Justin Wong.
Like...
Justin won 9 EVOs.
Bryan has won...
Bryan's a great coach, by the way.
Great content.
Great guys.
Great Street Fighter guys.
But he's not EVO.
He's...
He did great, though.
Bryan did great.
He taught me the fundamentals.
He taught me the fundamentals on Street Fighter for GEEF.
He was great.
But he's not Justin.
That's crazy.
I'm saying...
Ohh, RIP Bryan.
Guys, I'm saying...
He was great.
He actually helped me a lot.
Look, Bryan did the impossible.
He like...
He made me learn how to block, guys.
Guys, all I'm saying...
Bryan actually did the impossible.
And he taught me how to block.
I don't like it.
But like...
I fucking hate it.
But...
But, Brian actually made sure I learned how to block and forced me to block and everything.
So, in the end, you know, like, people can fix me.
Like, my defense is definitely higher now than Tekken, that's for sure.
I think I am a better player, because I actually use my brain, in Street Fighter than in Tekken, because in Tekken I was basically head empty, unga bunga.
But in Street Fighter I actually have to think about what I'm doing.
And because I have to think, I have to be like, okay, I have to block this, and then he's gonna do that, and I have to read, like, what he might do next and everything.
And I'm just like, I fucking hate this.
Bro, bro, I hate this!
It's like I was I was hard-stuck.
I was hard-stuck Bronze for four no, I was hard-stuck bronze five for four fucking hours.
I was
Brawl pro and this I literally wrote I hate Street Fighter
I'm silver one now, by the way, I'm silver I'm silver one now, but it was not a good time
It was so fucking, I'm so, I'm so done.
I'm so fucking done
This is at 547 a.m.
Oh my god, it was just it's just not a great time for me
It's not a great time.
I guess I just I need to like understand I don't know how to do, I still don't know how to do combos guys Is getting silver in three days good or is it that bad?
You know what?
No There's so many bronze and silver players while I was queuing if they've been silver for like fucking Five plus months and they're still in silver you're fucking dog shit.
I'm sorry
I'm just trying to make myself feel better.
I'm sorry you guys
Hey, it took me three days to get to silver it took me three days I Was very miserable, but it took me three days
No, you don't understand I hate so I blocked so many people like Like any time when I queue up a rank and I get anybody that was like a thousand plus points above me I blocked them afterwards.
I was like fuck you Why am I fighting you and it one game block Why block because I found help if you block them afterwards you don't get them again You know you don't get them again.
I was like fuck off Why am I against you you have a thousand plus points above me?
Why are you fighting me?
You don't?
I don't know what I'm doing I blocked everybody though.
I I am blocked everybody right after don't worry.
I I made sure I'm not sure to unblock everybody before the stream so that you guys won't see my block list.
You guys won't see the people I blocked.
I blocked everybody that like pissed me off and had like a thousand plus points above me.
And I just didn't want to fight them again.
I was like, no, get out of my queue.
I am so tired.
I'm trying to learn and I'm so tired.
I'm getting fucking demolished by people who actually know what they're doing.
I'm so tired.
Oh yeah, I won and done to everybody by the way.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter that like I beat them or not.
I won and done to everybody.
Like I had... I like...
I treated everybody equally by the way.
I treated everybody the same.
I do one game and I'm done.
I don't want to see you again.
A win is a win and I don't want to see you again.
I already had a miserable time fighting you.
I already had a terrible time fighting you.
No matter what.
Even if I won, I didn't have fun.
Blocked.
Oh wait, not blocked.
Um, quit.
Blocking was only reserved.
For people above 1000 points above me.
That's...
No disrespect on an elite level.
This way.
Anyway, alright.
I'll message...
Justin that I'm ready.
By the way...
By the way, Brian made me fight people more than once.
Also, the reason why I won and done is because it makes me so happy.
Especially when I won and done people with a winning streak.
Because I know how much that pisses them off.
If they lose to me and they had a winning streak...
I don't even give them... I won and done...
Oh my god, it made me feel so good inside.
Won and done-ing that.
I was like, 6th winning streak...
Wow, it would be a shame if you lose that.
Anyway, quit.
Now you're actually just evil.
But yeah.
I don't let people fire me.
And I don't fire people.
That's how I am.
Please don't promote this behavior, Doki.
Guys, it's okay.
Guys, I don't know...
I'm new here in the FGC community.
Guys, I'm just ignorant.
I'm just ignorant and I'll still be ignorant.
Like...
Please, dude.
It's pretty messed up.
It's my first day.
It's my first day, guys.
Okay.
Anyway, I didn't won and done when I was on Brian's stream.
I actually played my games out.
Because my coach judged me.
And like...
I only won and done...
Twice.
I only won and done twice.
During Brian's stream.
Because I ruined some...
I ruined a Marisa's 7th game winning streak.
And I was like...
No, you...
You're...
I was like...
You're not getting a rematch.
You lost your...
You lost your bonus?
Oh my gosh.
What a shame.
You lost your bonus rank XP from me?
Guess we'll never see each other again.
And I won and done on stream.
And I also did it to...
The last game I did on the stream.
Just because I was like...
I won.
I was like...
This was my LG.
I won.
Okay, bye.
Anyway.
I'll message Justin for real now.
I'll message Justin for real.
I'm not that toxic.
Right?
Alright.
I'm in the...
Sajam Slam Discord.
VC.
All right.
Let me make sure my Discord thing is...
Okay.
All right.
I'm gonna make sure I have everything set up for this.
Oh my god.
Guys, I think I played...
I think I played Street Fighter for like...
Ugh.
10 hours today.
I'm not okay.
Like not...
I think 8 hours?
No, I'll say 8 hours.
I did 5 hours of rank.
Yeah.
And then I did...
2 to 3 hours.
I think 2 hours of...
Ryan?
7 hours.
7 hours of Street Fighter.
And I guess we'll get to 10 today.
We'll get to 10.
We'll get to 10 today.
That sounds...
Guys, why did you think I...
Guys, why do you think I wrote this?
That sounds terrible.
This was my mental.
This is how I felt.
Like this is how I was mentally at that time.
It was not okay.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
They hate me...
They hate me by playing Modern Geek as much as I just...
As I hate them.
Alright!
Let's see.
I got a message.
Ohhh.
Okay, I'll just call him.
I didn't notice he has no perms.
Hahaha.
He doesn't have perms in the voice chat.
Like what the fuck?
He's the assistant coach.
I was in the public PC.
Oh hey!
I didn't realize you had no perms.
I got nothing.
I just have access.
I just can view.
That's it.
But you're the assistant coach!
How do you have zero access as an assistant coach?
Maybe they forgot.
I don't know.
Oh my god, they forgot the Justin Wong?
That's fucked.
That means you're washed now.
Yeah, you know, I think they were upset that I turned down the coaching role.
They were upset.
I was like, I can help, but I don't want to full-time it.
Damn.
And then they're like, alright, permission revoked.
You can only get FOMO and just look from the outside.
You can just watch everybody else have fun.
You're like, I don't know.
You're like that Squidward meme where you're inside.
You're just looking out the window.
Oh yeah, it's house and everything.
That's a good one right there.
I can definitely see myself just staring outside.
Everybody at TwitchCon having fun.
Wait, why couldn't you coach anyway?
What took your time?
Just busy.
My daughter, she's five and she's going to kindergarten.
Yeah, yeah.
So I'm not going to have time to be able to...
Yeah, you gotta spend time with your kid.
You know?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You gotta make sure that...
Okay, I shouldn't say it.
I was going to say something.
Out of respect, I wouldn't.
I won't say it.
Are you online?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm online.
Yeah.
Oh, I got the invitation.
Wait, is that your invitation?
Like, Chaeyoung?
Yeah, that's me.
Okay, okay.
All right.
I'm heading over.
Okay, so I want to go into the training mode and see what do you know?
Oh, that's a good question.
I watched the last three of your matches.
Yeah.
And you had really good reactions with the level three.
So I was really impressed with that one.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, really?
Everyone keeps going, whoa, when I do it.
But it's like, what's the easiest out of everything?
That was because you were aware.
That's the most important part.
Yeah.
I have eyes.
Trust me, people's eyes sometimes a little bit slow, so I'm not sure.
Okay.
All right.
Let me...
I'm just adjusting the volume real quick.
All right.
Yeah.
I saw that when you do drive impact, right?
You go for just this, right?
Yeah.
The yeehaw.
I would say sometimes if you get the drive impact...
Let's say, can you drive impact me?
Yeah.
Okay.
And you could do this as well, too.
You probably know this.
Yeah.
The...
The auto heavy combo.
Yeah.
I feel like that's really good as well.
I know you like to use this move.
Yeah, I do.
It's like I use this and then the heavy punch.
Yeah.
This move...
Have you used this move at all?
Yeah.
I have used the slap.
The slap.
Yeah.
I would say...
I would say use that more because especially if you're like here, it's like really...
It's going to be really hard for people to punish that from the silver level.
Yeah.
Right?
Like see...
Because if it says counter hit, you get the guaranteed three hits.
Okay.
But I guess like the range...
Which range is better?
Is the range for the cartwheel more or...
Or just that?
So it's because...
It's because let's say you do the cartwheel.
Yeah.
I can...
I can literally go to the...
To the bathroom, come back and still punish you for doing that.
You know?
All right.
Do it.
So like I...
So like it's good.
But that would say if...
People would be like, oh look.
Yeah.
Like just block high.
And then you're like kind of like...
Okay.
In a bad situation.
So just do this instead.
Okay.
I would say don't do it as much.
You know, you change it up a little bit.
Right?
Yeah.
And when you jump like...
What button do you like to use for jumping?
I just...
I like to do the down X.
Yeah.
And then what do you do after that?
I do this and then poke, poke, poke.
And then smash.
So what you could do if they block this.
Like yeah.
Just block it.
Yeah.
Just go to grab right away.
Oh, okay.
Just grab right away.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yep.
And then now let's say if they know...
If they think you're going to grab, that's when you go poke, poke, poke.
So think of it as like when you put me...
When you make somebody block.
Yeah.
You choose heads or tails.
So your head...
Think of like your head is the command throw.
Uh-huh.
And then your tails is poke, poke, poke.
Okay.
Right.
So it's like you constantly get the people guessing and then that will help you like in terms of like making more... getting more damage on the table, I would say.
Okay.
I see.
Because if somebody is like...
Let's say somebody coaches the other person when you're fighting and they're like, yeah, she only just does grab.
So just hold up.
Okay.
So then every time you will go for a grab, they just hold up and your grab will never work.
Yeah.
Right.
So then you have to put the tails option.
Where like, okay, if they hold up, let's say you do that string, like jump in and press the light and then do that one.
Yeah.
Just press it right away.
You see, I can't hold up there.
Yeah.
I get hit.
So then now after you do two, two of the lights, like two of that after.
Yeah.
Go into the OD.
Okay.
Yeah.
So try that.
Okay.
So don't can't don't press it right away.
Just wait a little bit.
No.
Okay.
That's just reflex.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
So you have to do the OD.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I'm getting it.
I'm learning.
Yeah.
And then do you use this move at all?
Oh, not a lot, but sometimes.
Okay.
I think like when I'm like head empty and I don't think I bring it out.
So this is also a very strong button.
So if you do, so if you do jump in with this, the medium, you can also go into that.
Okay.
As well.
And that really is strong because think of this as like they can't press a button afterwards.
Uh huh.
So like for example, I want you to do head butt and then into this button right away.
Okay.
All right.
You see, you see how it says counter hit?
Yeah.
I try to press the button.
I can't win there.
Okay.
And then.
And so now once you do that, you can go for the command throw.
Command throw.
Okay.
So after the head butt, square square and then command throw.
The OD.
Yeah.
The OD SPD.
Okay.
Right.
Or, or let's say you, you know, they're not going to press a button because they're, they, they're scared of you doing this after the head butt.
Yeah.
And then you, uh, can you block for me?
And you just go into the command throw.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, you're okay.
Okay.
That was too fast.
At least you're, at least you're good at canceling.
Most people are not good at canceling.
I'm trying my best.
Oh.
You do.
Yeah.
You just have to wait.
And then you do it.
I'm very impatient.
Yeah.
I'm trying my best.
Another thing that's really good as well too.
So can you block low?
Yeah.
It's just doing, cause I want to teach you like sequences.
Cool.
So you just follow a sequence and then you just literally, it's like reading a book.
Like it's like reading, like how to, how to, how to cook a scramble egg.
You know, you watch a YouTube video and you're like, okay, step one, step two, step three.
Okay.
Right.
So you do auto heavy crouching, crouching light, auto heavy crouching light.
Oh my God.
Okay.
That's.
All right.
Okay.
I can do this.
Yeah.
There you go.
See?
Uh huh.
Whoops.
Yeah.
Just don't match it.
Just don't match it like that.
Look at that.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
So you can do up to three times.
Okay.
And then now.
After the third time, what do we do?
So after the third time you do.
Okay.
Back special.
Oh, that's my favorite.
Yeah.
I know.
I saw.
It's my knowledge check.
If they don't check it, I'll just do it.
Okay.
Now do it.
Yeah.
You got sequences.
Right?
Okay.
And let's say in the middle of it, you're like, okay, they're going to keep blocking it.
So now block.
Okay.
Tick, tick.
I am almighty.
Oh my God.
Oh, and then it's throw time.
Yeah.
Cause you're in range to go for the throw after the headbutt every single time.
Okay.
I see.
Oh my God.
Yep.
There you go.
So if you, if you mix that up a lot, that helps a lot.
Another good sequence.
Yeah.
You have to press it one time.
Don't press it two times.
That's all.
Oh, whoops.
I'm so used to button mashing.
It's hard to button mash in this game.
I know.
I learned that the hard way.
Nice.
So another one you can do is, uh, could you block low for me?
Yeah.
Cause if you do three, uh, the crouching lights like this and afterwards do forward medium.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh.
Yep.
So now the reason why you do that is, um, can you, can you press start?
Um, and can you hit right bumper or what are you, what are you playing on?
I'm playing on a leverless.
Okay.
With PlayStation symbols on it.
Does it say right bumper?
Yeah.
Right bumper.
When you press, when you press start, you know how there's like three settings.
It's like basic settings, screen display settings.
Oh, basic settings.
R1.
Uh, what do you mean by that?
Oh, like if you hit, if you hit start, you got that purple menu that come up.
Yeah.
R1 and L1.
Can you hit R1 to go to screen display settings?
Screen display.
Yeah.
And can you turn on the frame meter?
Okay.
Yeah.
Now you see this.
Have you seen this bar before?
Oh yeah.
Everybody else, all the professionals have it.
Yeah.
Okay.
And all the same jam slammers, except for me.
Until now.
All right.
I don't know how to read this.
Blue means...
So just know this.
So blue means good.
Red means bad.
Okay.
So now, for example, do the, do your cartwheel.
Oh.
You see that number?
Yeah.
The seven.
Seven.
Yeah.
So that's, it's red.
It's red for you.
So it's bad.
Yeah.
Right.
So now do the headbutt.
The headbutt.
Okay.
You see?
That's blue for you.
It says four frames.
Yeah.
So that means, that means...
Do you remember like simple math, like negative one, negative two?
I'll have you know, I almost failed math, but like, yeah.
We can try.
We can try together.
Okay.
All right.
So this button, right?
This is, this is, um, I, I'm not, I'm not trying to, I don't want you to remember the map.
I just want to give you an example.
Yeah.
So this button is six frames.
Okay.
Just say the number six.
Why does it say eight?
What?
No, no, no.
Don't look at that.
Okay.
Just look at the number of startup.
Look at the startup number.
Okay.
It's just six, right?
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
You play like card games.
What type?
Goldfish?
Solitaire?
That's not the type of card game.
I'm talking about like, all right.
You know what?
Alright.
Like what?
TFT?
Like Pokemon.
Yu-Gi-Oh.
Oh.
That's outside of the...
I collected them.
Cause it looked pretty.
Really?
They were pretty.
Alright.
So now...
Could you block low for me?
So...
The headbutt is...
Right?
Hold down back.
So this is plus four.
Meaning...
I get the four frames.
I got the blue.
And you got the red.
So that means you have the red four.
Okay?
So if you have red four...
And you press your...
Your six...
Your six frame button.
Which is this one.
That means...
That means you add on to that.
So that means it's...
That means it's number ten down.
Right?
Yeah.
So that's why you lose.
Okay.
Just know that anytime you do something...
That's blue and you're blue...
You can keep...
Attacking.
If you're red...
You cannot press any button.
Okay.
Okay?
Yeah.
So if you do...
You press this three times...
Into forward medium.
Right?
Yeah.
So keep doing that.
So you see if you wait...
If you do that sequence...
Hold on.
Like...
If you block low for me.
Yeah.
Like if you...
If you time it right...
This will give you advantage.
Meaning like...
Like you'll turn blue.
Right?
Okay.
So let's see.
Yeah like...
I was able to turn blue earlier.
But like you could turn blue...
When you use this sequence.
So when you do this...
You can go into this right away.
Oh yeah.
Oh no see.
Oh my god I'm on the right side.
I don't play on this side.
No!
Don't do this to me.
I'll just grapple into the other side.
It doesn't work like that.
I'll just...
No I'll do this.
And then I'll...
Oh wait not that side.
I'll do this.
And then...
Okay.
So I'll do this.
And then I'll be on this side.
And then I can do this.
So you don't understand.
I can't.
I don't understand the other side.
What if...
What if they call for like...
What if you start as P2?
I'll just be like guys I'm...
Guys I'm really bad at...
I'm really bad at P1.
Can I get P2?
And then they'll put me on P1.
That's the trick huh?
Yeah that's the trick.
Yeah I'll be like oh guys can I please have P2?
I'm so bad at P1.
And then...
Give me P1.
Okay okay.
Alright.
Try this sequence again.
Okay.
Yeah so...
Do it one time.
And after that...
Do the OD SPD.
Okay okay.
We have to do the OD part.
Yeah do the OD part.
Because the reason why...
We have to do this one...
Is like let's say you're right here.
Yeah.
My OD SPD will hit here.
Okay.
But if I do...
If I do the OD one...
Oh I didn't know that's the longer range.
And...
Yeah it's a very long range.
So like even from...
Maybe from here.
You see?
We should use that like earlier.
Because I'm...
Look you see?
It's gonna miss.
So like yeah.
Right here your heavy SPD.
If you press special move.
It will not grab me.
Okay.
Yeah there you go.
Oh I'm doing it.
There you go.
Alright so now I want you to practice that on the right side.
I think I'm just a prodigy at this point.
Oh first try right there.
First try.
First try on this side.
I told you I'm so bad at...
Alright.
What do you do if I...
If you do drive impact to me when I'm in the corner?
Drive impact?
I'm in the corner.
Yeah what do you do here?
Oh I could do that or...
Was it this and then...
Sorry.
And then oh no.
It was like this.
Oh you want this?
Yeah.
So what you could do.
If it's easier for you.
Yeah.
Just mash, auto, medium.
Hold the assist and press medium, medium.
Oh okay.
Yeah so do that when I'm...
When you drive impact me in the corner.
Oh whoops sorry.
Okay.
Oh I see.
No so don't...
Just press it two times.
Press it two times.
Okay.
Yeah so you could do that.
And right after that when I get up.
Go for heavy...
Go for the special move grab.
Special move grab?
Yeah just press special.
Okay.
Oh whoops.
Oh yeah.
Don't mash.
Two times.
No.
There you go.
And then wait for me to get up.
Okay.
And then you just grab right away.
Almost, almost, almost.
Don't worry.
Get up.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Alright get up.
Alright I just say that to myself.
Yeah that's a good timing.
Hahaha.
Get up.
You...
So instead of saying get up.
Yeah.
Like obviously do that because the timing when you say it's very good.
So instead of saying get up.
Replace get up with drive impact again.
Drive impact again.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay okay.
Drive impact again.
Hahaha.
No no I mean like.
So when I mean drive impact again.
Do drive impact again.
Hahaha.
I was like wait.
Okay you want me to say that.
That's the get up.
That's the way.
Hahaha.
Get up.
Do a little bit faster.
Let me show you what.
Hahaha.
Haha.
I see.
Oh so you can like spam it.
Until you are tired.
Yeah until you are tired.
But obviously they can react.
We are back with Drive Impact back.
But they have to be quick with it.
Okay.
Remember how I mentioned to you earlier that I want something to always be heads or tails?
Yeah.
So think of this as another situation with heads or tails.
Where you do Drive Impact, do the combo, and then you can do Drive Impact again, keep doing it, and then I'll say this time they go for the Drive Impact back, you go for the throw.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
I understand.
Alright, get up.
No!
I didn't say get up!
You didn't say it!
I didn't say it!
You forgot to say clap!
Okay.
Oh shit.
Whoops.
Alright.
I got this.
Get up.
Yeah.
So the only thing I would say is that you need to do the Drive Impact, the second one, a little bit faster.
A little bit faster, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I'll tell you when and you press it.
Okay, okay.
Yep, go for it.
Press it.
Goodbye.
Yeah, don't do that.
That is a goodbye.
Yeah.
Try again.
Press it.
Yeah.
Grab.
No!
Almost.
But I feel like you understand Yeah.
what the situation is, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So now I want you to see Yeah.
Do the same thing.
Drive Impact.
Go for the combo.
And this time I'm going to think you're going to Drive Impact me.
So I'm going to Drive Impact on my wake up, but I want you to grab instead.
Okay.
Yeah.
I got this.
Yeah!
You see?
So you beat my Drive Impact.
Yeah.
I did.
Right?
So that's...
Yeah, so that's going to... I feel like if you can do those type of sequences, like the one we just did there, this one, right?
And go into that.
That would just give you more like layers for offense.
Because like when I watched your matches, like you normally kind of just go for like this move all day.
My favorite!
This is your move.
It's my knowledge check!
It is.
So think of this like, let's say think of this when you're doing this.
You can also do it from this way.
Yeah.
You can do it from the jump in button that you like to use.
Okay.
Alright.
Oops.
Yeah, one jab.
Okay.
Oops.
You're okay.
You say lag?
I lagged there mentally.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
See, you could do more of it in the corner, obviously.
Yeah.
So that's gonna be really good.
Now...
Alright.
Do you know how to drive rush?
Drive rush?
Yeah.
Is that right?
Do you know how to do...
I know you like to do this.
Hold on.
Oops.
Wrong button.
This.
That.
So I want you to do drive rush into that.
Ooh.
Because look, from here, it goes really far.
Yeah.
But that's really good to use as well.
That?
Okay.
So do it as early as possible because the momentum will carry you.
Yeah, I like that.
Yeah, you see?
Yeah, it will just carry you.
Ooh.
And you can also do this as well too.
Like you do drive rush or charge it.
Ooh.
Sorry, that's my dog.
Yeah, you're fine.
Yeah.
Oh, like, yeah, just charge it.
Yeah, like that.
Alright.
Because let's say somebody tries to attack you when you turn green.
Yeah.
Like, this will happen.
Oh, yeah.
Like, do it to me.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
Whoa!
Yep.
Okay.
You see?
So that's really good.
Yeah.
So now let's say you think they're going to block it.
Like, block this button or block this button.
Then you change it up with drive rush that one.
Okay.
Because that's your low option.
Yep.
So think of that as like this like this into this or into this.
That's like your rock, paper, scissors.
Okay.
I'm going to see if I can remember all that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's all heavy buttons.
It's always the heavy buttons.
Yeah.
Don't press any other buttons.
Yep.
Oops.
You just choose between that three.
Because your goal is to get them like knocked down close to the corner as possible.
Yeah.
Right?
Because then you can go for the drive impact thing that I showed you.
So, do you know how to do press a button into drive rush?
Press a button into drive rush?
Like this.
What?
How did you do that?
Press standing light kick.
Standing light attack.
Oh, okay.
Hit that button.
Yeah.
And then you tap forward, forward.
What?
That's a move?
Or you can press parry button right away.
The parry button will do it automatically.
Oh my god.
I could've been doing that?
Yeah.
It's very That's what I want you to do, actually.
That's the perfect thing.
I want you literally to do this.
If you can do this, this will help your chances so much more.
Oh my god.
Exactly.
That is literally how you get free grabs.
I could've been doing this.
Yes.
I'm glad.
I didn't have to tell you.
You already knew what you needed to do.
Oh my god.
The only bad part about this is that you can only do it two times.
Because you'll get tired after two times.
Okay.
So you just have to be careful.
Alright.
Actually, you can do it three times if you think about it.
Yeah, they'd be dead by then, right?
Almost, almost dead.
Yeah, almost dead.
Yeah, because you can even do like if you're feeling funky with it.
Right?
You can even do this.
Oh!
Level three.
Yeah.
So you could do that as well.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, yeah.
So you could try it.
Okay.
Oh, whoops.
Yup.
Oh my god.
He won't expect it.
Yup.
So, so, so.
But like literally if you could just get this down like...
10 out of 10.
Every single time.
This will help you get so many more options of grabs.
Oh, I see.
Oh my god.
This is gonna be my new favorite move.
Yeah.
Even at the highest level, this, like, that works.
Oh my god.
Yeah, don't press down.
It's so easy now.
It is very easy.
Oops.
All right.
Yeah, you can also do this as well too.
Let's say you're like from really far.
You could drive rush into the back, into the into the back throw.
Yeah.
Like this.
Cause you know how like, do you know like from here it's fast, from here it's slow.
Uh huh.
Yeah, yeah.
Like he like lifts his hands up.
Yeah.
And you, let's say, you see this line right here I'm stepping on?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So if I drive rush to the line.
You see how it looks like it was I was still running, but I go into a throw.
Yeah.
So that can really catch people off guard.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yep, exactly.
Oh, I see.
Yep.
All right.
Yeah.
So that could be a thing as well too.
If you want to keep going for more throws, right?
Uh huh.
And let's see, I like the fact that you do this move a lot.
I saw you like air one.
Yeah, this.
Yeah.
So if somebody jumps at you, what do you do?
Oh, this one jumps?
This?
Yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
All right, all right.
You can also you can also, let's say let's say if you it's too late to do this move, because sometimes it's a little bit too late to do it.
Oops, sorry.
Let's go for parry.
Parry, okay.
Yeah.
Yes.
Have you tried to do perfect parry before?
Um, yes and no.
Sometimes it happens.
Like it happens, right?
Yeah, like this.
So what do you do when you get that perfect parry?
I don't know.
Just press press the special move button right away.
Okay.
Oh, no.
No.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So only do it when you get perfect parry.
Okay, this is going to take a while.
I'm just kidding.
I'm trying to time it to your hit.
But my hit is random.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
You did it.
Teamwork.
Yeah.
So that's also really good.
But let's say if you're in the corner.
Yeah.
So I'm going to knock you down like this and I want you to wake up with parry.
Oh, wake up with parry.
Oh, okay.
Wake up with parry.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, I'm sorry.
So when that happens, I want you to back throw me.
Okay.
Try again.
Not the special back throw.
The regular back throw.
Like this one.
Oh, okay.
The regular.
Okay.
Oh, whoops.
Yeah, yeah.
Try again.
Yeah, it has to be perfect parry.
If it's regular parry, don't go for that.
Okay.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Eventually it will happen.
It looks so cool on stream when it does happen, right?
It does.
It looks so cool.
It'll happen, guys.
On one of the round robins, it's going to happen.
Because this is your best defense.
Yeah, okay.
Okay.
So you should always wake up with it.
Anytime.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
No, I fucking...
You didn't expect it.
I didn't expect it at all.
Okay, okay, okay.
This time you were expecting it.
Yeah, yeah.
This time.
Okay.
There you go.
No, wrong throw.
No!
We can do this.
Oh my god.
But it looks so cool, guys.
Back.
It's okay.
I'm just practicing the perfect parry.
That's really it.
Back throw, back throw.
Okay, we did it!
Now, after the back throw.
Yeah.
You do the ODSPD right away.
Okay.
Because it'll look like this.
Watch.
So if I do it.
You get up.
Whoa!
That's a lot of damage.
Yeah, so try that.
Okay.
You got it.
When did we get there?
Oh, god.
Oh, I see.
Also, when you're going for the parries, make sure you're holding down back at the same time.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So if you mess up the parry, you'll be...
blocked.
Okay.
Oh, god.
Oh, my god.
Back throw?
That's okay.
ODSPD?
We did it!
Guys, I'm totally gonna do this stream.
It's gonna work.
You know what it is?
If you...
So the hard part about it is obviously like all the stuff that we're...
I'm showing you, it's like remembering it, right?
Yeah, yeah.
I'll be surprised if I retain 50% of this after.
So think of it like this, it's like when you go, when you play your matches like online, like when you're practicing, think about, okay, I wanna land this one thing that I learned.
I wanna land this other thing.
Don't think about winning the match.
Think about like, okay, I'm going to do this.
And if you land that, then think of that as the win.
Okay.
Yeah.
What was that?
What happened?
I think we're still in.
Wait, you left the room.
Where did you go?
Are you still in?
Yeah, I'm still in.
Where did you go?
Oh, I got kicked off.
Is this Steam?
Today's Tuesday?
No, it's Monday.
It's a long weekend.
It is a long weekend.
Yeah, it's Monday.
Are you playing on PC?
Yeah.
Why my game is wrong?
Why is your game wrong?
It's saying I can't log in.
What the?
Did you get hacked?
Live?
Imagine.
Justin Wong gets hacked live on stream.
Let's see.
Wait, wait.
I think I'm back in.
It's like loading.
It didn't give me the error.
Yes, we're back in.
That's weird.
That's spooky.
I'll wait for your custom room.
Capcom wasn't feeling it.
You used up your modern gif credits.
I did.
Ban for Sajam slam collusion.
If you were going to coach one person, you should coach them all.
I coached a few people.
Wait, who else did you coach?
Amore.
Oh, yeah.
Boxbox.
We had a thing this past weekend at PAX.
I had to coach him as well too.
I know Sfan hit me up.
So I got to talk to him as well.
As long as none of them are in my division, that's fine with me.
Who's in your division?
Wait, wait.
If I bribe you, can you not coach me?
My division is...
That sounds like a corrupt coach.
I mean, if you want a modern gif to win the beginner division and to represent all modern gifs out there, I feel like it's in your favor to not let them beat me.
Oh, okay.
So are you the Division 1?
I'm the beginner.
I am the very, very beginner.
Silver is pretty good for that first level.
Is it?
I was expecting maybe Iron and Bronze to be the first level, but Silver is pretty good.
I'm pretty sure a lot of the beginners are already in Silver.
Oh, maybe.
But if you learn everything that I showed you, you can get to Gold at least.
Oh.
Okay, I'll try my best.
Did you get my invite?
Let me check.
I did.
Yeah, I'm coming in.
Maybe by the end of the day I'll be close to Gold.
Okay, you're fighting against Blanka, right?
I'm fighting against Blanka, Bison, Lily, Cammy, and Aki.
Okay.
So I'm gonna show you probably what moves they're probably gonna be spamming.
And what you can do against them.
Okay.
Alright.
So now, it's probably this move.
Oh my god, you look like a tomato.
Oh yeah, that's my color.
It's probably this move right here.
Yeah.
So what you can do is you can press down special when it gets close to you.
Okay.
Yep.
Yeah, so like, that's gonna be the main thing for you to counter.
So if you can do that every time, then he can't do that anymore.
Then they have to have a different game plan, right?
Yeah.
The other thing they'll do is obviously jump.
So you gotta be ready, because the jump is super fast.
Yeah, so you just have to be ready with the Lariat.
Okay.
Oh.
Yep.
Another thing is that, can you block low for me?
Oh yeah, that move.
So if you block, so you can try to tap parry before the electricity hits you.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you can obviously get, if the timing hits, perfect parry.
But also, yeah, you see, and then you go for the throw.
Yeah.
Also, what you can do as well is that if you block it, right, so like block low for me again, you can press you can press a button after that.
So press like your fastest button.
Oh.
Yeah.
Yeah, like that move.
Okay.
Yeah, see, I can't press a button there.
Oh, you pressed the button.
Yeah.
It was a missed time.
Okay.
So what you can do here, do two of the crouching lights you did into back special.
Oops.
Yeah, so just remember to do that.
Okay.
That, okay.
Or...
Okay, yeah, what was it?
You mean this move?
Yeah, that move.
You have to block it low.
Sorry, I got up.
Yeah, yeah.
Think of this as the same move as your forward heavy.
Yeah.
Where it just, you can literally walk around the park and punish it.
Okay.
So if you block it, you do you do the command throw.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's easy.
It's a punish counter.
Meaning you do more damage.
So look, watch.
See, like if you do the throw regularly.
Yeah.
Right, it takes that much, a little bit over the C on my letter, right?
The life.
But now, watch, block low and then do the command throw.
You're fine.
And look at the life.
It's a bit more.
Yeah, yeah.
Right.
Can you block this again and don't do anything, actually?
Oh, don't do anything, okay.
Yeah, I just want to see the number.
Okay, 18.
Can you press your auto heavy?
Auto heavy?
Okay.
That's 14.
Alright, so you can even do that.
So block low and just do auto heavy target combo.
Yeah, just do it faster.
Yeah.
So that works.
So if you have level 3, you can combo into it.
Okay.
Yeah.
So that will punish it really hard.
Let's go!
Yay!
So now, you probably see this move.
Oh yeah, this guy.
So what would you do against that?
Jump?
Just hold parry.
Oh, okay.
Because even if I'm coming towards you, you know what I mean?
So go back, watch.
And if I activate it, yeah, just hold parry the whole entire time.
You see, you just parry the attack.
So the only thing...
Hold on.
Let me reset here.
How does Blanka get his dolls back?
I don't know.
Chat, it's time to backseat.
Any Blanka players?
Any Blanka players in chat?
Which taunt is it?
Oh, there we go.
That?
Yeah.
Alright.
So now, the only thing that he can do while you're holding parry is if I grab you.
Oh yeah, Blanka players love that.
Yeah.
And that's okay.
It's better to take the grab compared to taking the more bigger damage in the future.
Oh, okay.
So if you just see this, I feel like most of the time if it's like a low...
If it's like a beginning Blanka player, they'll probably just do this all day.
Yeah.
I've seen a lot of Blankas that did that, yeah.
Yeah, so let's see.
If you...
Let me get that doll again.
So hold parry for me.
So if I do that...
And then they do the second slide, then you would be able to get the big punish that you just learned.
Which one?
The auto heavy.
Oh.
We learned so many.
I had to be specific.
The auto heavy?
Yeah.
Let's try to do it a little bit faster.
Okay, okay.
There you go.
You just have to let go of parry right away after you parry the third hit.
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah!
There you go.
This is your last ride!
We did it!
Look at that.
That's big damage.
Okay, that's half.
So now this move is very annoying.
Yeah.
So what you want to do is obviously you can parry everything.
But if they come at you, you could do Larry or you could do jump command throw.
Oh, okay.
Like the jump special grab.
I did time that.
Yeah.
So you could do that.
Yeah, you just have to be a little fast with it.
Yeah.
Whoa.
No.
You can even do the OD one to do more damage if you want.
Okay.
Yeah, this is probably the most annoying.
Yeah.
His thing is faster than the other jumps.
So if it's from here, then you go for the jump throw.
Yeah, okay.
If it's from here, then it's much harder, obviously.
Then you can do Larry or hold parry.
So it's between those two options on whatever you feel comfortable with.
Oh, it still hits.
Yeah.
As long as it comes out, it will always hit.
Okay.
But like obviously the thing is that he can kind of change the trajectory to not come at you.
Yeah.
Right?
If you wanted to.
So that's the one thing you have to be careful about.
Oh, yeah.
And then you bait me.
But that's okay.
I think even if they baited you, I think it's fine because it's only from far away that they can bait you.
Yeah.
If I do it from like right here, I can't bait you.
Like the Larry will always hit.
And you can probably do the level one super.
Do you use the level one super at all?
Oh, no.
I just save it for level three.
Okay.
So against Blanka, it's not necessary, but Lily is very necessary that you have to use the level one.
Let's see.
Let's go.
I'm going to pick Lily.
Yeah.
This is actually Zangief's hardest matchup.
Like no joke.
No joke.
The reason why is because of this move.
Like this move is just very, very annoying.
Oh, yeah.
No, I'm having PTSD right now.
Yeah.
Was that what you learned?
I have some PTSD from this guy.
Okay.
So now, when you see this move, do the level one super.
Just, you know, press the...
I don't remember what it was.
Special move heavy.
Special move heavy?
Okay.
Yeah.
So watch.
We're going to go one, two, three.
Okay.
One, two, three.
Let's try again.
I'm going to do the slow one first.
Yeah.
Okay.
Is there a slower version?
That is a slow version.
Okay.
I'm going to start from far.
This is...
Oh, shit.
The range.
Yeah.
Oh.
That was too fast.
It still works, but you want to do it when you see it come out.
You see?
Because you don't want to preemptively do it.
Okay.
There you go.
Good job.
Yay!
Get down.
Now I'm going to do the fast one.
Okay.
Nice.
Down, little girl.
Yeah.
So that is like your saving grace of that one.
Okay.
So now the other one that you have...
players like to do is obviously this is their favorite button in the world.
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
So what you want to do is you want to block block it, like block low.
And they're going to do this.
Okay.
They're right.
They're going to do this.
So what you do is you just, when you see this move, you drive impact.
So drive impact before this move hits you.
Okay.
So you drive impact after the two hits.
Alright.
There you go.
Okay.
Because the Lily players will always go for this because this is like her best way to get wins.
Yeah.
Get down, child.
But the only thing...
I don't know if the other Lily player will learn this.
Is that if they do the fake one like this and you drive impact, I can drive impact back.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
So I'm not sure if they will do that.
But if you do see that, just know that I told you and don't blame me if that happens.
I will 100% blame you.
That's all I'm going to say because like...
Now that you say it out loud, she's going to know now.
How do you know?
What if she watches my fun?
What if they're like scouting us out?
I got to cover the bases.
I don't want to be on record.
Justin Wong has told me to when I see this move, drive impact every single time.
If I don't make it to the finals, Justin Wong coached me.
Changing the words up a little bit.
So now...
So now the last thing is that let's say...
Can you block low?
Yeah.
Let's say you block this.
And you remember how the headbutt if you press headbutt if I block headbutt, you press button, I press button, I lose.
Remember that?
So this is the same thing with her.
If you block this move, you can't press button.
Okay.
Right?
So...
What you want to do is...
There's two ways.
Let's say you're like I don't like the pressure.
I don't want to deal with it.
Just do hold forward and while you're blocking hold forward and press drive impact back.
So like do it while blocking.
The kickoff thing.
Okay.
Yeah, the kickoff.
So you do that to get off of me.
Or...
If you think...
Because what they can do also is they can go for...
Let's say you don't do that, right?
Okay.
They can go for...
Oh yeah, that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So what you do is if you think that move is coming you hold up right away.
Okay.
You see?
It misses.
Yeah.
So then you come down press heavy and press auto heavy right away.
Oh.
Yeah.
So you can do all... you can come down and press your heavy button and then you do auto heavy.
Yep.
Goodbye little girl.
So that's pretty much you're going to be your big counterpicks against... Uh huh.
Against Lily.
Okay.
So...
So I'm going to ask you what do you remember?
Okay.
I remember...
the get off button.
Uh huh.
So when you do the thing and then...
Okay, when you do the thing now...
I do this.
Okay.
And then the other thing.
This one, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What do you do on this one?
Um...
Give me a sec.
That's okay.
Drive impact.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, remember before the third hit hits you.
Yeah.
This one.
Okay.
And what do you do when she does this move?
From far?
Oh.
Like let's say before...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh no, I'm on the other side.
You still only press two buttons.
You don't need any direction.
You just press the two buttons.
It's not that one.
It throws me off.
Left hand, left hand, left hand.
I know, I know.
It just, it throws me off.
Are you ready?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm actually ready for real, okay?
I'm ready for real.
Okay, okay, okay.
This is tournament on the life right here, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you do, if you land this you win the tournament for your whole team.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh my god!
I won Twitch Rivals!
Let's go!
And with the tea bag too, huh?
Yeah!
Okay.
So now let's say if you don't want to spend the drive reversal and you block it and Lily goes for a command throw, what do you do after this?
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay!
Remember?
Oh, you gotta block it.
Block low.
Okay, okay, he's alright.
Woo!
Oops.
Or the, uh, heavy, auto-heavy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Yeah!
We're doing it!
Boom!
Alright, I'm going to teach you a very scrubby strategy.
Oh my god!
I love scrubby strategies!
Because I think this will work a few times.
So we'll see.
Oh my god.
I'll only use it in the finals so they won't train for it.
Alright, I'm going to do it and see how you deal with it.
I'm going to do this.
Oh yeah, this!
Yeah, yeah!
You know about this?
Yeah, I try to do it in ranked.
I failed spectacularly.
What the fuck, man?
I don't even know how to deal with it from other characters.
I mean, you have the right idea with the parry.
Yeah.
So that's something that you can probably do for like a few extra hits.
Do you know how to do that move?
Yeah, I do, but like...
Yeah, there you go.
I try to do it in ranked, but I got fucked up.
So what you can do is after you... let's say you land that, go to the special move right away.
Okay.
Yeah, wait a little bit.
There you go.
So you can do that as well too.
Or you can do auto heavy as well too.
Remember, the heads or tails.
Yeah.
Yeah!
My loyal fan.
Okay, and what other...
You said Cammy or Bison.
Yeah, Bison.
Who's playing Bison?
Canna.
Another VTuber.
Do you know if she's playing Modern or Classic?
Modern.
I know that Blanka, Bison are playing Modern.
I think Cammy, Aki, and Lily are Classic.
Okay, yeah, okay.
Let's go to Bison.
Where's Bison?
Bison just has scissor kick.
Scissor kick.
That little tornado shit.
That little tornado thingy that they do.
That shit's fucked.
What, this move?
Hold on.
No, the...
Yeah, that shit.
That's so fucked.
Like you don't like this move?
Oh, fuck that.
If you block it, they die.
Oh.
Yeah.
It's just...
It's so fast.
No, just sit there.
Just sit there, okay.
Yeah, because I think with your match, like when you play, you hold forward a lot.
Oh, yeah.
No, I didn't pay $70 to block.
But now I am blocking.
I'm blocking now.
Okay.
So what I want you to do, think of it like this.
Like 1, 2, 3, down back.
1, 2, 3, down back.
Just a little bit more of that.
Yeah, exactly.
If you move around like that, there's less chance of you getting hit by this by just off of random.
This move is really good.
So what you want to do, if you block this move and let's say they do it from this close like that, you do OD SPD.
Yeah, okay.
So do the OD special grab.
Alright.
Yeah.
That's a punish.
I can't avoid that.
Okay.
I can avoid that one.
That has to be the regular one that you just did.
Yep, that one.
Yay!
So I think this move is also annoying.
So this move, if you block this, you can't press a button.
I'm blue here.
Okay.
Yeah.
So what you want to do is try the lariat.
Okay.
Oops.
Yep.
Okay.
And now, this move, if you block this move right here, you can press...
Let's see if you can press auto heavy after this.
Yeah, there you go.
So that works too.
Yay!
So now, the tricks, some of the tricks you have to respect when you're fighting against Bison.
Okay.
So don't block.
Have you seen this move?
The little thing on your stomach?
Yeah, I have.
Oh yes, I have.
What do you do against this move?
I don't remember.
It just disappears.
Once you see it like glow, especially purple, like it's about to blow up.
Yeah.
Just hold parry.
Like wait, wait for it.
I don't want you to hold it like right away.
I want you to hold it when it's like, when you see that like, oh, it's about to blow up.
Okay.
Just wait.
Go.
Yay!
So that's one way to stop it.
Another way is, if I overextend, if you hit me, like just press any button, it goes away.
Oh yeah, that's what happens for me.
It just disappears.
So now, the other thing is, let's say you, I have this move and you block and start blocking.
Yeah.
Yeah, so block.
Put a virus.
Yeah.
I automatically blow that move up.
Okay.
So that means, anytime I blow that move up on my terms, never press a button.
Never press a button.
Just block.
Woo!
Yeah, you just have to block.
Yeah, yeah.
Just remember that.
This move right here, if you block this move, don't press a button.
Okay.
Yeah, it's just one of those things that you just, like if you see this move, okay, they can still keep attacking.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, so it's kind of like your headbutt, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If I block the headbutt, then you can keep attacking.
So it's very simple.
Don't mash.
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah, yeah.
Yep, and then you go for the grab, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whenever you feel like it.
I mashed.
I would say that's pretty much that's pretty much Bison in a nutshell.
Oh, there's also this move right here.
Um...
Have you seen this super before?
Sometimes.
Not a lot, though, for this one.
Yeah, okay.
Just in case, if they somehow, if you see Bison go in the air, they can choose either left or right.
Uh-huh.
So it's kind of, you know, sometimes it's hard to block, like, oh, it's going to be on this side, so I have to block it, right?
So if you see this super ever, just hold parry.
Because it blocks both sides.
Yeah.
It will literally just block both sides.
And any time you block a super or you parry a super, you just do auto-heavy right away.
Yep.
Yay!
Yeah, you'll be able to punish every super with that, just like that.
Okay.
And even if you don't have three bars, you'll get the auto-heavy times two.
Like, do auto-heavy times two.
Okay.
Wait.
Yeah, you'll get that.
Okay.
Yeah, so if you don't have three bars, you'll just get that one.
Which is still pretty good damage, regardless, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, I got a hit on a Bison.
Dude, you got a hit.
Yeah.
And then Cammy...
Cammy and Aki.
Oh my god, I hate fighting.
I hate fighting Cammy.
Why?
Is you too fast?
It's the... it's also similar to tornado shit.
It throws me off.
Yeah, I hate that move so much.
I think once you learn, once you start doing like walk, block, walk, block, walk, block instead of just walk, then I think you'll you won't mind that move too much, because then you'll just block, right?
Okay.
So instead of doing this, like what you're doing, you walk, down, back.
Walk, down, back.
Yeah, see?
So it should be like that.
You see?
And then anytime you block Spiral Arrow, do special move.
Right?
So there's that.
The only other move... so the...
If you block this move, don't press button.
Yeah, don't press the button.
But if you see that move coming, you can press your crouching light.
Okay.
So try to press it before I hit you.
Oh, okay.
And then do it two times, and then go for the command throw.
Okay.
Oops.
So do it before.
Yeah, see?
Don't press button if you block.
If you block, don't press button.
But press button before it hits you.
And then, yup, and then go for the throw after you hit it.
No!
Yeah.
There.
Go for the special move button.
Do one, two, special move.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, you're fine.
No!
Yeah, not a cancel.
There you go.
So that's how you stop that move.
But remember, if you block it, don't press button.
Okay.
You can also, if you see this move coming, you can drive impact it.
Alright.
A little faster.
Yup.
Yeehaw!
Yeah.
Yeah, that's gonna be really good as well, too.
And then there's this move, the dive kick.
Oh, yeah.
This is really hard to stop with Zangief.
Like, sometimes the lariat won't work here.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so it's just kinda hard, but if you do it early, like you see, it'll sometimes happen like that, right?
Yeah.
But if you land the lariat early, then you'll win.
But let's say if it's a little bit too late, you always just, you can just try to parry it.
Okay.
Yeah, and then think of the parry as like an auto block.
Yeah, it's just like blocking for you.
Okay.
Yeah.
Understand.
The other thing is block low.
They might do this.
So what you wanna do is press your crouching light or press standing light before, after two hits.
Okay.
Yeah, like that.
Oh!
That's right.
That's fucking right.
There's so many camis and silver and bronze.
Try to press um...
Try to press crouching light.
Like after just two hits.
Okay.
Oops, sorry.
Yep.
So what I want you to try to do is do crouching light into down special.
Like right away.
Crouching light down special.
Okay.
Oh!
No!
There you go.
Oh, come on!
It's fine.
There you go.
So that's like your two hit combo for a punish.
Uh-huh.
Right.
So that's gonna be like your answer if you see them.
Because the thing is if you block the whole thing.
Yeah.
Let's say you block you can't press a button.
So you just have to remember that.
So if they like let's say you they do it to you in the match or on rank.
Uh-huh.
And you see them do it the first time.
Just be like oh I'm okay.
I remember.
That's not.
You can't do that.
I can press a button there.
You don't have to like.
Yeah.
Try to challenge it right away.
But it's just something for you to know that there is an answer to something like this.
Yeah.
Which is good.
Thank God.
Everybody please Cammy.
Cammy is a very popular character.
Alright.
This is Aki.
Aki.
I mean.
I'm actually surprised somebody is playing Aki.
I don't see a lot of Akis.
I don't see a lot of Akis or what the fuck.
I've never seen that costume before.
Oh that's costume.
You should have it.
It's costume too.
I don't know.
If you got the deluxe I think it comes with it.
Oh my God.
So.
What do you do against fireballs?
So what I want you to do when you fight against any fireball character is you do back back special move and heavy.
Oh.
It's like doing the level 2 super.
Okay.
Yeah.
So when you see the fireball do that super.
Okay.
Oh shit.
What the fuck.
So what I want you to do is don't hold.
When you do the level 2 super let go.
Don't hold it.
Oh my God.
I didn't even realize it sucks people in.
That's how little I use the super.
Yeah.
So anytime you see it.
Not that one.
Yup.
And it will do a chunk of damage if you don't hold it.
If you hold it it will do like that little Yeah.
A little cyclone thing where it doesn't do that much damage because you're supposed to combo afterwards but if you want to do something like that you can hold it and then right after I start flying in the air you do your level 1 super.
Okay.
Now do the level 1 super.
I am coming for you So it will look like that.
Okay.
But that's if you feel like wanting to do that but Yeah.
Yeah.
I want to clip a stream moment.
Clip a stream moment.
That's the one.
That is the one.
That's the one in game.
So Aki is really good at doing like moving forward like this.
Yeah.
So what do you do when you see players do this?
Do this.
Like drive impact?
Yeah.
So let's say do it again.
That's like why you have to be careful right?
Yeah.
What you can do is if you so remember how I mentioned in the beginning that some of your level 3's are like really good because you're using your eye and you're just doing it right?
So if you see the green come to you use the eye.
Alright.
I use my eyes.
Yeah.
So anytime somebody turns green and runs at you Yeah.
Right?
They cannot.
They cannot get out of it.
They cannot get out of this.
This is guaranteed every single time.
I see.
So you just have to remember that.
That's like the rule of thumb.
Also let's see there's this move.
So if you block let's say yeah just hold back.
If you block this you can press a button.
Okay.
You have to press.
When I mean press a button means press your fastest button.
Oh okay.
Yeah.
Yep.
Right and then now if you if you block this one.
Let's see.
Go back.
Yeah.
You cannot press a button.
Okay.
When you're yellow.
So she turns.
Yeah.
She turns yellow.
Don't press button.
But any other version you press button.
Okay.
Yep.
So now since you like to do the re-crouching punches right?
And then normally you don't have something like right now you have nothing to do after that.
Yeah.
So what I want you to do is when you see your three punches hit.
Okay.
Do three punches and then into drive rush.
Oh okay.
Right.
Oh no.
Yeah just tap the so you have to let go.
Yeah.
Let go.
No.
Come on.
Try again.
Yeah.
So do one, two, three.
Let go.
One, two, three.
No.
Yeah.
Okay.
So what I want you to do after you do drive rush is go into the command throw.
The special move.
Okay.
There you go.
Yay!
So now let's try it again.
Oh shit.
I just wanted to kick you.
Oh.
No!
Come on!
What the fuck?
That's okay.
A little bit there.
We could definitely get more cleaner.
Yeah.
Oops.
No!
Come on!
Oops.
Boom.
That was the cleanest.
Yeah.
That was the cleanest so far.
You can even do two if you want to do it faster.
Like that.
Okay.
That one was almost perfect.
Oops.
There you go.
Yay!
Woo!
So that's really good as well.
Let's see.
The only other thing with Baki is probably this move.
Oh yeah.
Fuck that move.
The little slide.
You don't like this move?
No.
That's shit.
So if you see, let's say I'm going to use this move to get out.
Yeah.
If you think I'm going to use this move, just press when you see me turn yellow, press special move.
Okay.
A little faster.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Because it loses to grabs.
Oh, thank god.
Yeah.
So try to do this.
Try to do...
Let's say you do the down forward heavy.
Okay.
And then...
Not that one.
Down forward heavy.
Yeah.
And then press crouching light afterwards.
Yeah, like on my wake up.
Like when I wake up, I'll try to use crouching light.
Okay.
Yeah, keep doing this.
Yeah.
Smash it.
So it'll be something like that, right?
Yeah.
So once you see me turn yellow, you go for the throw.
Okay.
No!
Get back here!
Yeah!
Nice!
So that works.
Yeah.
So if you could...
So if you think they're gonna try to slither their way out, always go for the throw.
Okay.
Just grab the...
Yeah.
Another thing you just have to watch out for is this... this stance.
What the fuck?
What is that?
Yeah.
Oh shit!
I think this is the first time I've ever seen that.
What the fuck?
So let's say, if you see them... if you see them do this, just hold up.
What the fuck is that?
Like, it's like Lily's command throw.
Oh, okay.
I swear I've never seen this before.
Just in case.
Yeah.
Just hold up.
Hold up.
Okay.
Yeah, hold on.
When you block first...
It's just so creepy.
Yeah, block first and hold up.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
Hold up and not a direction.
And then remember the punish that you did against Lily's command throw?
Yes.
Yeah.
Sorry, I buffed you.
Do the same thing.
Okay.
So you could do that as well too.
That's the same thing.
Alright, now we're gonna do the hardest thing.
What is it?
We are going to do a review.
Oh.
I just wanna see how much...
No.
No, not the surprise quiz.
Alright, alright.
So, what do you do with the... what do you do with the headbutt?
That.
Yeah.
Or...
Or that.
There you go.
Yeah!
Alright, that's one.
Now, what do you do if you drive and impact me in the corner?
Oh!
I'm coming over.
Yeah.
Or...
Or I could do this.
Wrong button.
Get up.
Okay.
No!
The time they're on!
You got it.
No, but you're right though.
Get up.
There you go.
Yeah!
Alright.
Now, what do you do with this button into drive rush?
Oh.
Wait.
Let me see.
Yeah!
There you go.
Okay, okay.
Let's see.
Boom.
Learning.
Do you remember...
Do you remember this one?
If you do three punches, then what?
Oh, wait, wait.
What?
Give me a sec.
What do I do after that?
What's the button that you press after that?
What's the button that I press after that?
Give me a sec.
The little...
The little knee?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Give me a sec.
Medium.
And then what do you do after the knee?
And then...
Oh, not that, but it's also yellow.
Okay.
Yeah, that's right.
You're not wrong.
And then...
Yeah.
There you go.
Alright.
So now...
Yeah, I think...
I think that...
Yeah, that's literally the four things with Zangief.
Definitely, I think the...
Your favorite one is probably just...
Oh, yeah.
Alright, now I know...
That's like your favorite one.
Now I know how to do this.
Okay.
Oh, that's right.
There's one more.
What do you do...
If you just do dry brush?
What are you pressing?
I'm pressing...
Just dry brush?
If you do, let's say from here...
Dry brush...
Oh, I know.
I know, I know.
I fucked up, but I know.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, I fucked up again.
Don't worry, I got this.
Don't press a button.
Just hold parry and then dry brush.
Oh, shit.
It's rock, paper, scissors.
Rock, paper, scissors.
Whoops.
Yeah, and then...
That, and then...
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I did scissors again.
There you go.
Yeah.
See, you do remember.
Yeah, I remember.
Yeah, you remember this.
That's the most important part.
Okay, so now you have these five things that you learned from Zangief, right?
The five sequences of Doom.
Yeah.
So now, when you play online, you have to land at least three of them.
Okay.
At least three of them.
You have to land three of them, I would say, a few times, so it's in your muscle memory.
Right?
Because...
You know, like, if you know how to do this in training mode, it doesn't mean it applies in a real match.
Yeah, I agree.
Right?
So that's like the most important part.
So if you can do it in an actual match, I think that's going to help you a lot.
Okay.
I hope I can do two of them at least.
Yeah, I think two or three.
I think the standing light drive rush into the command throw, I think you'll do that pretty well.
I think even the heavy, the auto-heavy light, auto-heavy light, you were pretty consistent as well, too.
Yeah.
I think.
Do you remember what to do against the other characters?
Do you remember those a little bit?
I think so.
I...
Like if Lily flies at you?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Level one or like, uh, level one or there's the drive rush or the jump and then heavy.
Yeah, yeah.
Level one.
Level one or block and then jump up if you think she will command throw you.
Okay.
Alright.
And then you go for the jump coming down, heavy, auto-heavy big combo.
Okay.
Alright.
And then, remember walk and block.
Walk, block.
Count, count, count two seconds.
Count two seconds, block low.
Okay.
I gotta time myself.
Yeah, count.
It's like how you were doing your sequence of like, get up.
Yeah.
It's the same thing.
Count two seconds, block low.
Count two seconds.
Yeah.
I'll be like, walk.
Walk.
At least it's not dash.
That's the most important part.
Yeah.
But yeah, I think.
How do you feel?
I feel.
I definitely feel like I gained more knowledge on how to cheese on Gief.
Yeah.
I definitely gained more.
That was the goal was teaching you how to cheese with Gief.
Yeah.
That was the most important part.
I just need to apply it.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah.
I think that's it.
That's it for now.
I don't want to give you too much information.
I think like That's a good idea.
It's a good amount.
I'll definitely, if you have any questions, obviously you know how to reach me.
Yeah.
And then I will check your future matches after today to see how it goes and I will let you know.
Okay.
This is what you did right.
This is what you forgot to do.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Okay.
Do you want to watch like a few rank matches?
Yeah.
Sure.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me disappoint you today.
Okay.
Let me get in real quick.
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
Alright.
Let's see.
Street Fighter.
Alright.
Let me know if there's frame drops.
I don't.
Because there were frame drops during the...
I think I fixed it during the during my session with Brian.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's like fully fixed.
Alright.
You know what?
I feel like wild.
I'm gonna accept everybody.
Oh.
Even the Wi-Fi?
Yeah.
Even... I don't discriminate.
Okay.
I'll let fate take me to a game.
Dun, dun, dun, dun.
Even here, like while you're looking for matches is also where you can like practice your stuff too.
Yeah.
Ooh.
Three times is usually the max.
Oops.
Oh my god.
Please.
No.
Not her.
Okay.
If you think she's gonna command throw you, hold up.
Anytime there's a command throw, you just hold up.
Oh.
No.
Please.
My coach is watching.
Don't fuck me up.
Just have fun.
Go grab a lot.
Yay.
Holy fuck.
Ooh.
Nice.
The headbutt.
Yeah.
See?
Headbutt.
Oh, thank you for throwing.
We can't stop the headbutt.
Let's go!
My favorite move cause it works.
Oh shit.
Never mind.
Don't let me go, please.
Okay.
Kill her.
Yeah!
Oh, I could have done the other thing.
Don't worry.
I'll bait her.
Watch this.
Oh, you got it.
Don't worry.
Watch this.
I'm gonna bait her.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Watch this.
I approve of that.
That's the stuff I like to do.
I'm getting her a false sense of security.
You made her feel like, Oh, look.
I can go in.
I have to think about it.
Yeah.
You're about to be silver too.
Oh shit.
I'm gonna be silver too?
Oh, she wants a rematch?
Nah.
Oh, that's toxic.
She said nah.
You're like, I don't want those free points.
I want a harder opponent to get my points.
That's why you did it.
I wanted her to see my rejection too after she asked for a request.
Oh shit.
Mirror match.
Alright, this is a test.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
No.
No, he's silver.
Please.
He played Modern too.
He might have your guides open right now.
He might.
He might be watching your stream right now.
I have brought a lot of Modern Zangiefers.
Oh, you caused this?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
He's doing a thing.
Holy shit.
He did what I showed you.
Oh, fuck.
He's throwing me off.
It's okay.
It's a mirror of yourself.
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
He's doing it.
Don't mash though.
Remember, don't mash.
Okay, it's fine.
He's dead.
Oh my god.
He has your stream open right now.
It's like, I just learned this from I just learned this from his stream.
Okay.
No, you got it.
You're up at the window.
Wouldn't this be funny if it works again?
Yeah.
Wouldn't this be funny?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
You were close.
Don't mash.
Oh, that's a key right.
Yeehaw.
I'm fucked too, but that's alright.
It's okay.
Oh shit.
I'm putting false sense of security.
Let's go.
He could do the same thing.
Wait, no, he jumped.
No, he jumped!
You fucker!
No!
You're still alive.
Don't worry.
He jumped.
That's so fucked.
What kind of side people are you?
We don't jump.
We hold forward.
Alright, you have to jump.
You have to jump.
Nice!
Good job!
I did that!
Yeehaw!
That was a really good reaction.
That's a key right!
Alright, I'll let you rematch me.
That's right.
Yeah, he gets the honor.
He gets the honor.
Oh, is he gonna quit?
You fucking pussy!
He was thinking about it.
Nice.
Wait, this move is actually so good.
What the fuck?
I told you, yeah.
That's the button.
He has an iron head.
What the fuck?
That's funny.
I didn't realize how good this move was.
Remember, blue is good, red is bad.
That move is always blue for you.
Okay.
Oh no, this guy's...
Maybe I shouldn't have accepted everybody.
Don't worry.
Akuma...
Oh.
Oh, that's why.
Because you accepted Wi-Fi probably.
Yeah!
Oh no.
His internet's not letting him play.
Alright.
You have to win this.
It's the rank up opportunity.
Oh god.
He bleeds.
He doesn't have much life.
So if you grab him like three times, he dies.
Please let me grab you.
My coach is asking me to grab you.
Oh god.
Remember, hold parry.
Yeah.
That's fucking right.
Okay.
Let me headbutt you.
No!
It's okay, it's okay.
Alright, yeah.
If you hold parry, you get back drive gauge as well too.
Yeah.
Mm, nice.
Oh no.
Don't do that though.
Yeah.
You're spending bar for that.
Oh my god.
He's fucking me up.
Alright.
New strategy.
Okay.
Jumping medium into auto heavy.
Jumping medium to auto heavy.
Fuck!
Oh shit!
Okay, I looked down.
Yeah, so you can get it started.
Oh.
Okay.
Almost, almost.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah, anytime you get a knockdown, you can go for the auto heavy stuff.
Oh no, now I'm tired.
Alright, wait for the fireball.
Or not.
Okay.
I'll wait now.
I'm forced to wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Remember, when he throws fireball, you can do your level 2 back, right?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Yeah, just wait for it.
He's gonna throw it.
Please.
Come on, don't you wanna throw it?
Throw it, throw it!
That's fucking...
That might be a little too late.
No!
He just watched!
Please.
My coach saw that.
Okay, jump.
Jump medium.
You're almost there.
No panic.
I feel so embarrassed.
I feel so embarrassed now.
No panic, no panic!
No!
It's okay.
We were just learning Ray.
We just wanted to fight him again.
Whoa.
Hello there, sir.
Okay.
Yeah, if you block that double kick when you're blocking low, the second hit misses.
Oh my god.
This guy knows what he's doing.
There you go.
Alright.
Yeah, you just have to block.
He's not grabbing you, so you shouldn't worry.
If you block, eventually an opening will come to you.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Get closer.
You can't run forever!
Yeah, there you go.
Yeehaw!
Alright.
Don't forget about the standing light attack into the command row.
Please!
That's actually what I was trying to do, but now I'm running into fireballs.
Alright.
You can't parry.
I know.
Jump over.
Oh.
Round two.
Okay.
I can do this.
I like this.
Oh, I forgot my cage!
What happened?
You spent a lot there.
Slap!
I didn't realize.
Get closer.
Fireball.
Level two.
Alright.
Ooh, nice!
That's fucking right.
Just block.
Hold back.
Never mind.
Alright.
Jesus Christ, please.
It's okay.
Level two.
Don't forget.
Alright.
Oh, not there.
What the fuck?
Okay, buddy.
Okay.
Almost!
You just need to get into the headbutt range.
Yeah!
A little bit faster.
It was a counter hit.
Alright.
Just do it a little faster.
Okay.
You got level two again.
Wait for it.
Oh my god!
I heard level two and my instinct went...
Press button.
It's okay.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Just walk and block.
And jump over the fireball like Mario.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god!
Please!
No!
I'm so fucked up!
You almost had it though.
I think if you...
The only thing...
I think that there's no Akuma's.
Yeah.
The only thing you messed up was if you leveled two at the right time, then you would have won both of those matches.
Right?
It's just more you just have to get used to just seeing the fireball and then doing level two like in accordance.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
It's the same thing.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to fight the Pope.
Okay, but wouldn't it be funny if he doesn't block this?
We can't block it.
It's a grab.
Sorry, man.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry, Ken.
I'm sorry.
I thought it'd be funny.
There you go.
No mash.
Okay.
No more.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Yep, yep.
Please, let me get closer.
You don't have to get close every time.
You can just wait.
Yeah, armor.
Remember the Drive Rush armor?
Drive Rush RPS.
Okay.
That's five.
You are safe.
Yeah!
Good job!
I did it!
It sucked!
Let's fucking go!
Oh, oh.
Oh, shit.
Spy, you're in grab range.
What if I do it again?
Keep doing it.
Oh, shit!
I should have rock, paper, scissors it.
Don't forget the Drive Impact.
In the corner.
Alright.
Alright, level one super.
Yeah, if it's airborne like that, you have to do level one super.
What the fuck?
It's okay.
You got level two again.
Oh, never mind.
You're good.
Yeah, the slap is really good.
Yeah, get out.
Oh, he didn't want to fight you.
Good.
Get embarrassed.
He was mad.
That's right.
I hope he finds this stream.
Oh, shit.
No,
it's a different person.
Yeah, his name is Copper Moth.
You got to take his streak.
Alright, Copper Moth.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, he's slapping.
Yeah, that's a good button.
Yeah.
No.
You pressed the wrong button.
Yeah, but I did it now.
That's fucking right.
Yeah.
Nice.
Yeehaw, get out.
Yeah.
.
That's fucking right.
I'm faster.
My APM is faster.
Not that one.
That's so slow.
Yeah.
That's a slow one.
No, shit.
That's your move.
That's my move.
I was on pause.
He's doing the thing.
The driving back in the corner.
Oh my god, he's just slapping.
You got to block the three hits.
Oh my god, he's doing the thing.
Look at him.
It's okay.
Okay, it's okay.
We're just both okay.
Oh my god, he definitely has your guide out.
What?
No, you're good.
You're good.
That's not going to work.
That's fucking right.
You're right.
I let you watch too.
Get over here.
Oh, shit.
But not now.
Get over here.
I'm going to bait you.
Do some more damage for him.
Okay, now get over here.
Now get over here.
You know you want to.
Oh, he's so scared.
No, I don't make it do.
You have to be close.
I played around with my food a bit too much.
I was just fucking around.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
Don't forget about the drive rush.
Oh no.
R.P.S.
No.
You chose Spock instead of R.P.S.
It's fine.
I won.
Okay, you did.
Slap.
I slapped harder than I ever slapped before.
That's fucking right.
No!
He fucking pressed triangle.
Yeah, right jump.
Oh, shit.
Remember.
You do the auto heavy.
Yeah.
Get the big combo.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, stop.
Stop slapping because I'll do it back.
Nice.
Yeah, I'm faster.
I have faster APM.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, the range.
ODSPD.
We'll grab there.
Okay.
Nice.
One more hit.
No.
Oh, shit.
I couldn't get out.
Dropkick.
He fucking dropkicked me against the wall.
Remember the lariat.
Yeah, that's right.
If he jumps at you.
That's fucking right.
Do it again.
Oh, goodbye.
It's okay.
Yeah.
The lariat.
Don't forget about the lariat.
Yeah.
That's fucking right.
Do it.
Keep jumping.
You know you want to.
You could jump at him too.
Nice.
Idiot.
That's fucking right.
Get destroyed.
Yeah.
Rock, paper, scissors next time when you land that.
Okay.
But what if he doesn't...
It won't work one day.
If it's the fast one, I believe it.
Not the slow one.
I'm throwing.
No.
Alright.
This is the comeback time.
Okay.
I won't throw this time.
I swear.
No.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Wrong button.
We gotta wait.
Oh no.
No!
The whole time I throw.
He thinks it's tactical.
Okay.
I won't throw for real.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Please.
I can't throw anymore.
My coach says I shouldn't.
You guys jump.
Nice.
I like that.
You have like the read on what to do though.
Yeah.
When you do drive rush.
Oh that was great.
Drive rush into RPS not grab.
Oh.
Please stop slapping me.
Jump.
No.
That's your move.
That's my move but he confuses me.
I think you win.
Yeah.
Cause I'm like wait.
You can't use that.
That's the move I use.
Oh my god.
I hate when he does that.
Lariat.
Yeah.
Do that again.
Do that jump again.
Jump.
Nice.
Get predicted bitch.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Kill him.
Yeehaw.
Okay.
I'm scared now.
Wait that hits right?
Yes.
Told you I'd stop throwing.
Told you I'd stop.
That was a good level 3.
Almost.
Like one more match away from dying to silver 2.
I think I could've got it if I didn't throw.
Yeah probably.
Two goals.
You gotta do the RPS.
And then the drive rush.
Oh.
The drive rush and you choose either Rock Paper Scissors.
Oh okay.
It's him again.
Hey.
It is him again.
Hey there.
Why are we still here?
Oh.
A little too fast.
Okay.
Oh.
Almost.
I have to be back to neutral.
Trying to do it.
Nice.
Let's go.
It's okay.
It doesn't matter.
You did it though.
He knows though.
Alright go for the splash right here.
Jump over and splash.
Oh shit no.
That's not what I wanted.
The splash would've hit.
Slap.
Oh shit no.
Oh that's gonna hurt.
Oh my god.
I'm fucked up.
Sir please.
Alright.
On wake up.
If you ever get knocked down.
I want you to just wake up.
And jump.
And don't.
It's that wake up button.
Okay.
I think he learned.
I think he was learning.
You're not supposed to learn.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
You're good.
You still got this.
You just need like three big hits.
Woah woah woah woah woah.
Don't forget about your headbutts.
But he also has modern.
He might look for the level 3 too.
Wait.
The guy I played last time was classic.
Who is he?
This is the first thing if you thought.
Oh the first one.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I was like wait a minute.
There's like three Zangiefs that you fought.
So far.
And they're all different.
Oh my god.
I thought they were all just one giant Zangief.
No no no.
No wonder he played different.
I was like why don't you jump?
Why aren't you doing the dropkick?
Yeah.
Why are you doing the stuff I did before?
I was like did you like...
Took my knowledge?
Oh yeah.
He's the guy that followed our guide.
Yeah.
He did everything that we were doing.
Okay.
RPS.
No.
Jump out.
There you go.
What?
Holy shit.
He's better.
He's just better I guess.
Alright.
You have to do level 2 on reaction.
No.
That would have worked.
Yeah.
That would have worked too.
Yes.
That was me.
I was like what color am I again?
You're the default.
I couldn't tell for a sec.
That's right.
Keep slapping.
That button is so good.
Get slapped.
It's okay.
That's fine.
If you get knocked down, just jump up.
Just hold up.
Okay.
Every time you press buttons, you always get hit on the window.
Just jump.
Okay.
Oh.
Alright.
You have your level 3.
My.
No.
He slapped me.
He jumped.
You fucker.
Okay.
I already don't have energy left.
I might as well.
No.
You have.
Oh.
My.
That's...
What?
It's the armor.
It's the fucking armor.
How did you learn so fast?
I beat him before.
That's the button that you...
That's the button that you use.
That's the special move that you use.
No.
He used it against me.
You just have to...
When you see the arms go up, you just gotta jump.
Alright.
Oh.
My.
God.
Where did all these Zankeeps come from?
I guess they've been watching the last two hours.
They're like, wow.
I gotta put this into motion now.
Now that we...
I watched...
Justin teach Doki how to play Zankeep.
I'm gonna go into rank now.
You did get the standing light attack and drive rush into...
I did.
SPD.
So now you just gotta do the RPS where you just drive rush from full screen and just choose what you want to do.
Whichever heavy you want to choose.
Yeah.
I need to figure that out.
Just rotate it.
Don't do it like that.
It has to be raw drive rush.
Oh wait.
Yeah.
Just raw drive rush.
There you go.
Alright.
Fight me opponents.
My chat is like Justin is mass producing Zankeeps.
That's a charge heavy.
That's good too.
You can use that as well if you want.
Get out of here.
Yeah.
That's the RPS.
Get that RPS going.
Okay.
I gotta remember this too.
Yeah.
Three times.
And don't mash it.
Yay!
Yeah.
All the games you won previously were all like from the headbutt.
I feel like the last few games you didn't go for too many headbutts.
Yeah.
I think I was just scared of the other geef grappling me.
I was like no don't do that.
The thing is if they block the headbutt and they try to go for the the grapple.
Your button will still win.
Okay.
The only time you'll lose if they do level three.
Oh god.
It's a Blanka.
Alright.
Just wait for the Blanka ball.
Wait for Blanka ball.
Lariat.
Oh shit.
Okay.
There you go.
Just wait for it.
And block low.
You can just always hold down back.
Remember hold parry.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh missed the armor.
Alright.
There we go.
Nice.
Play time.
Okay.
RPS.
Oh.
Alright.
Yep.
Hold parry.
Oh.
Oh no.
Get out of here.
Okay.
Alright.
There you go.
Wait for it.
No.
Oh my god.
Get out.
Stop.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
He's blue.
He's blue there.
If you block the rainbow ball, you cannot press the button.
Oh my god.
That was so slow.
I think I'm tired.
Are you okay?
I'm tired.
It's hitting me now.
After two thank yous, I realized I was like, I'm tired.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
This is the last game.
No.
Yeah.
It's okay.
You learned a lot.
Yeah.
The fatigue hit me hard.
I was like, oh man.
Now I'm definitely too tired.
Slap.
Alright.
Hey.
Just remember that like before the last three games when you were applying the stuff, you cooked those people.
Yeah.
Before the fatigue hit.
I think my coffee wore off there.
No.
I forgot to quit the match.
Okay.
This is the last game.
For real.
Maybe this person deserves the rank up.
No.
You deny the rank up.
Alright.
Just jump in splash and just go for the headbutt.
Oh shit.
Oh no.
I didn't check my gauge.
That's okay.
That is bad.
Jump splash.
Yup.
Uh huh.
Wrong button.
Yeah.
That's okay.
Hold up.
Just hold up.
No.
Stop.
I'm definitely so tired.
The fatigue has hit.
Yeah.
Anytime you jump up and they didn't jump up, don't go for the command throw.
Okay.
Only do it when they meet you in the sky.
I have enough.
Yes.
I had enough.
Alright.
Just wait for it.
Okay.
That's a good combo.
Yeah.
Oh.
Missed it.
Oh no.
Remember.
Hold up.
Oh.
Oh no.
Hold up.
No.
I'm still alive.
One more chance.
I pressed triangle.
Yeah.
You have to press circle.
You pressed circle.
You would have been good.
I pressed triangle.
You have to ban triangle in the air.
It's because I was tired.
Excuse me.
Ban triangle in the air.
Ban triangle.
The fatigue hit.
I think you learned a lot though.
Yeah.
It obviously showed before you got tired.
It hit like a truck.
Those two Zankees back to back took me out.
Okay.
Oh my god.
But that was a very informative coaching session.
I definitely learned a lot.
Oh yeah.
It was really fun.
Yeah.
I had a great time.
Thank you so much for coaching me.
Of course.
Anytime.
And good luck.
I think it was Wednesday, right?
Yeah.
First round.
Alright.
Good luck.
Thank you.
No problem.
Now we have a great time coaching everybody but the other beginner division players.
Okay.
Alright.
I will be watching anyway.
I'll talk to you later.
Yeah.
GG's.
Bye bye.
Oh yeah.
It was so fun.
I had a great time with this coaching.
I'm so tired.
I fucking played too much Street Fighter.
I played too much Street Fighter.
Oh my god.
But I had a great time.
A huge shout out to Justin Wong for coaching me today.
And for Brian for coaching me earlier today too.
So now I have like both coaches helping me out to make my gif a better... I'm so tired.
Make me a better gif player.
Anyway guys.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
I'm going to pass out.
I like went to bed at like 7 or 8 pm yesterday.
And then I woke up at 2 am.
And then I just grinded Street Fighter.
And now it's 6 pm.
Anyway.
I'm going to sleep.
My schedule is fucked.
I'll see you guys later everybody.
As always stay hydrated.
Pause check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.